how you doing Kevin America doing great
I'm still on cloud nine it was a
phenomenal week thank you
yeah walk me through what what do you
take out of that weekend Kevin well just
how special and how it meet the being a
hall-of-famer really is and how special
it was for me to be able playing in a
cell but the biggest thing that and I
knew it because I wrote my speech but
even now deceived my teammates and
friends from all walks of life show up
to write you know to be a part of the
celebration to really understand that
it's about your teammates and about
relationships and and those are the
people that kind of help you grow to
these you become yeah and and now your
relationship with your own teammates
from the canton class of 2019 I thought
it again the word beautiful is the only
one that comes to mind that you all got
together and donated money to the hall
in the name of Pat Bowlen and handed the
check to and you were the one to hand
the check to David Baker Kevin walk me
through how that all came together at
all prior to you know during spring or
whatever they bring you out to the hall
itself and they do a site visit for you
to come see the Hall of Fame to you know
visit where you're gonna have your post
your reception and and stuff like that
and then but they also give you mr.
Baker's The Dude's a walking cycling
feat encyclopedia and there's a there's
a doughnut wall and he made a point to
stop of the wall and show us the name of
one man who volunteers at the Hall of
Fame for a bunch of years him as like
both did and they sold their house I
think the Hall of Fame has bought some
of the houses around the property so
they can expand the facilities and a man
because of his connection in affiliation
with the Hall of Fame his love for his
wife her love of the Hall of Fame
they took some of the proceeds after she
passed away he sold them all so he
donated some of the proceeds from the
house sell to the Hall of Fame now
looking on a wall there may have been a
couple of players or maybe you know
management type people on the walls I
didn't recognize him registered you know
it's a shame the number of players that
come to the hall
all in the hall of famers that you know
somebody's name's not on there that a
player would recognize and I said in
Tracy and I talked about wouldn't it be
cool if our class came together and
donated you know donated something all
of Fame in recognition of our class and
so that kind of we was started and now
it's back in April and then pushed Pat
Bowlen passed away and then I thought it
was a really nice now the rest of class
did this in memory of him
and so I sent an email out to everybody
and pitch the idea and everybody was on
board and almost my opportunities you
know it was kind of on you because I
asked the Hall of Fame if I have five
minutes during the state of the hall
address with mr. Baker to address the
crowd and he wanted to know why I said
well it's just five minutes I want to
get something to Hall
you didn't even tell me ha no and so the
other thing too is there's a decorum
that you take it the first time all well
you know when you first get in the hall
that during that week it's about you but
the older guys are already Hall of
Famers they make you know that you're
not a Hall of Famer until you get that
jacket in the boss and so for me to
speak out early in the process during
the week I mean I had to address those
guys first letting them understand I
understand you know there's a rookie
hall-of-famer but I'm supposed to be
seeing not heard but I had this
presentation to make and when they found
out I was giving check they all backed
off yeah man and as I mentioned now you
set the bar already for future classes
and there's one that might be 2020
strong next year so good for you to
start that tradition Kevin Malloy Hall
of Famer here so who in the 16 plus
years that I've done this usually a Hall
of Famer realizes that it is don't it's
there not just for the jacket the bus
but when you see another Hall of Famer
welcoming you who was that one for you
that blew you away from this one know
was one day I said nothing before but I
saw him in the Halabi hotel and we met
we talked and he's like you you're gonna
be one of the good ones
it means one of the good members the one
who guys did that the heart will
represent the Hall of Fame well and
stuff like that not that really touched
me it was really you know nice and him
to say that and I just loved him I mean
no no of them had never really knew him
but for him to say that to me early and
that we it just meant a lot to me
of course I've known most of their guys
down in recent years and teammates or
opponents but but the one for little was
one of the ones and Joe Greene yeah I
played on Don Shula staff in the Senior
Bowl and Joe Greene was the defensive
line coach at the time so I've known him
for quite a few years and now knowing
him as a hall-of-famer is pretty special
few more minutes left with Kevin Millian
now you know we all we know the what
next you're an offensive analyst for our
zona State football Kevin how do you
analyze a game plan when you already
know you play to win the game Kevin how
does that work well I know I know that
uh what it takes to win a game I know
what it takes to be the best and my role
with an analyst with firm staff is they
get these guys to see the greatness in
themselves and everybody's got different
levels of greatness and as a mentor as a
future coach my job is to help them get
as much out of that as they can and be
able to pour it out on to other people
and so that's what my mission is and the
grown men and then encourage them to be
the best that they're capable of being
and uh and so I'm gonna do how it is
more like how did the locker room take
it back in the day when when that herm
rant that famed you play to win the game
the time that he gave the speech and we
ended up making a play off that year
pretty well so it worked and then again
you know um you know Kevin just seeing
that this is kind of a cherry on top for
you you know part of you know your
leadership skills what has been over the
years I've got two minutes left with the
Players Association do you have any
insight on what's going on right now
between the NFL and the PA with a new
CBA coming up I do not have a
negotiation session a few weeks back and
I've been asked about it and my opinions
on it and I won't
give them whatever opinion I have really
doesn't matter because what matters of
leadership right now and those guys that
I make decisions based on what their
priorities are for me I knew that what I
would do what my my soul eaters would do
wouldn't affect us but it would affect
the future of the game and my
encouragement to them is just do the
same let them know that they're not
doing it before themselves they're doing
it for the guys to come after them and
so they got to figure out what the
party's all stick to their guns and
fight their ass off the people they want
and would you one day want to take a
leadership role on this front again oh
no no I've done it I don't like the
politics of it I want to be on the field
I want to be around football players and
I want to be able to teach them the
craft that I know and that I love so
much and and maybe one of those guys
will emerge become leaders down the road
but I have no desire to put a coat and
tie on and sit across the negotiation
table phonies well great job with the
speech Kevin it was just beautiful what
you said to your folks and the message
you gave and you know calling your your
presenter hot you know that was great I
forgot that I forgot that adjective my
bad my the extra for the extra mile on
the adjectives and you know and getting
to know you when we first turned the
lights on on NFL Network and then seeing
the rest of your career it's been a
pleasure to be able to say that I've
gotten to know you and I look forward to
seeing you in Canton every year well
thanks so much man and you know I know
you do the radio TV and all that kind of
stuff
peanuts personality your friend rich not
thank you so much Unum and Kevin say it
see how to earn for me
say I will do I'm actually headed down
the practice field I'm wearing my gold
jacket are you are you really good yeah
I'm purposely on this radio show now so
I don't have to be there for walkthrough
right now and as they're starting to
walk through I'm coming down the hill
with my coaching gear on I got gold
socks on gold shirt Arizona State gold
and I'm wearing my jacket all right
tweet us a photo Kevin well I will
definitely I'll definitely do that send
that out
my right now say hi to her for me you
take care I'm glad we could be of
service to Kevin why to get out of
walkthrough for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app